[Applause]
he's back after maintaining the
traditional diplomatic silence of an
outgoing President Barack Obama has
returned to the political front line to
attack his predecessor it did not start
with Donald Trump he is a symptom not
the cause we're supposed to stand up to
discrimination and we're sure as heck
supposed to stand up clearly and
unequivocally to Nazi sympathizers
he's Donald Trump worried apparently not
I'm sorry I watched it but I fell asleep
I found he's very good very good for
sleeping mr. Trump's on a short tour of
reliably loyal Republican states but
it's the disloyalty of one of his own
staff and the White House which
continues to wrinkle he told reporters
aboard Air Force One he wants Attorney
General Jeff Sessions to trace the
anonymous author of this week's article
in The New York Times
we investigating
because I really believe it's an essence
and in their action that should be taken
against the New York Times probably
it sets up another potential ryo with
mr. sessions has been trying to maintain
the independence of his Justice
Department from political interference
though the president raged on Twitter
that the article was treason and his
cited national security it's not clear
what crime has been committed no
classified information was revealed and
freedom of speech is protected under the
First Amendment but the president is
determined to root out the mystery
author I don't mind when they write a
book and they make lies because it gets
discredited we just discredited the last
one we discredited all of them because
it's lies but I'll tell you when
somebody writes and you can't discredit
because you have no idea who they are
usually you'll find out it's a
background that was bad it may not be a
Republican it may not be a conservative
it may be a deep state person that's
been there a long time
you don't know where it's a very unfair
thing but it's very unfair to our
country and to the millions of people
that voted really for us they voted for
us the interview was conducted in the
middle of a campaign rally to spell out
his belief that this was an attack not
just on him but on those who voted him
into office in woods Sky News Washington